This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. You've heard the old joke. A pedestrian in New York is looking for directions to the city's most famous musical performance venue. He sees a musician get out of a cab and asks, How do you get to Carnegie Hall? The musician answers, Practice, practice, practice. I'm guessing you didn't even crack a smile.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。你一定听过那个老笑话。一位行人在纽约问路，想去城里最著名的音乐表演场地。他看到一位音乐家从出租车里走出来，便问：“去卡内基音乐厅怎么走？”音乐家回答：“练习，练习，还是练习。”我猜你连嘴角都没动一下。
That joke stopped being funny a long time ago, and not just because it's familiar. It's become something of a truism. We all know that practice, grit, and determination are keys to success. If you want to be better than everyone else at something, you have to outwork everyone else. There is much truth to the story of grit and drive.
那个笑话早就不好笑了，不仅仅是因为它太老套。它已经变成了一种陈词滥调。我们都知道，练习、毅力和决心是成功的关键。如果你想在某件事上比别人做得更好，你就必须比别人付出更多的努力。关于毅力和干劲的说法确实很有道理。
We've explored research on the show that says that conscientiousness is one of the best predictors of academic and professional success. But today, in this episode, and in a companion story on our subscription feed, Hidden Brain Plus, we explore a paradox. There are many domains in life where practice and effort fail to work their usual magic. In these areas, it's effortlessness that triumphs over effort. Trying your best or trying too hard can produce worse results. Understanding why effort and grit can sometimes backfire and the underappreciated skill of letting go. This week on Hidden Brain.
我们在节目中探讨过相关研究，称尽责性是学术和职业成功最好的预测指标之一。但今天，在这一集中，以及我们在订阅频道“Hidden Brain Plus”的配套故事中，我们将探讨一个悖论。在生活的许多领域，练习和努力并不能产生通常的神奇效果。在这些领域，不费力反而胜过费力。尽力而为或用力过猛反而可能导致更差的结果。了解为什么努力和毅力有时会适得其反，以及“放手”这一被低估的技能。本周《隐藏的大脑》。
There are times in our lives when we find ourselves beset with challenges. We toss and turn at night, thinking of ways we can extricate ourselves from our problems. But no matter what we do, nothing seems to work. At the University of British Columbia, the philosopher Edward Slingerlin has explored the counterintuitive benefits of just letting go. Edward Slingerlin, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me. Ted, I want to take you back to the time in your life when you were in your early 20s
在我们生命中，有时会陷入困境。我们彻夜难眠，绞尽脑汁想办法摆脱困境。但无论我们做什么，似乎都无济于事。在不列颠哥伦比亚大学，哲学家爱德华·斯林格林探讨了“放手”所带来的反直觉益处。爱德华·斯林格林，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你的邀请。泰德，我想带你回到你20岁出头的那段时光。
and you lived in San Francisco. You were interested in meeting women and you tried hard to make romance happen. Tell me what you did. I remember vividly going through this dry spell where I was really actively making an effort to meet people. And I would do things like go to a cafe and leave my Chinese philosophy books very prominently displayed on the table I was working at and my motorcycle helmet next to me on the chair,
那时你住在旧金山。你很想结识女性，并努力想要开启一段浪漫关系。告诉我你做了什么。我清楚地记得那段空窗期，我当时真的在积极努力地结识他人。我会做一些事情，比如去咖啡馆，把我读的中国哲学书显眼地摆在桌子上，把摩托车头盔放在旁边的椅子上，
thinking, okay, this is how it's gonna work. So I'm gonna walk by and think, wow, that guy reads Chinese, or he rides a motorcycle, and they'll start talking to me. And that, in fact, never happened. And looking back at it now, it's pretty clear, trying to get a date is not a good way to get a date, so that was not very successful. I remember being at one party and wandering to the edge of a conversation where people
心想，好吧，这样应该管用。这样别人走过时会想，哇，那个家伙读中国哲学，或者他骑摩托车，然后她们就会开始跟我搭话。但事实上，这种情况从未发生过。现在回想起来，很明显，刻意去寻找约会对象并不是获得约会的好方法，所以那次尝试并不成功。我记得在一次聚会上，我徘徊在谈话的边缘，听人们
were talking about what they studied. And they were all people who worked in the restaurant industry but were going to school part-time. And I wasn't really listening to the conversation for conversation's sake. I was looking for a chance to insert myself. And someone mentioned philosophy and I said, oh, you know, I study Chinese philosophy at Stanford. And everyone in the conversation kind of looked at me and they were like, yeah, it's really fascinating. Thanks. And they turned back to the conversation.
谈论他们学习的专业。他们都是在餐饮业工作但兼职上学的人。我并不是为了交流而听，我是在寻找机会插话。有人提到了哲学，我说：“哦，你知道吗，我在斯坦福大学学习中国哲学。”谈话中的每个人都看了看我，然后说：“哦，真迷人。谢谢。”然后他们就转回去继续谈话了。
It was just this clumsy attempt to insert myself into a social situation. And that was annoying. You know, I understand that at one point, this was back in the day when we all rented movies at a store, you tried to catch the interest of a woman who worked at the video rental store. Paint me a picture of what you did, Ted. I was trying to figure out some way to start talking to her. So I went through a Vim vendors phase.
那只是一次笨拙的社交介入尝试。真的很烦人。我知道，在那个我们还在店里租录像带的年代，你曾试图引起在录像带租赁店工作的一位女性的注意。给我描述一下你做了什么，泰德。我当时在想办法跟她搭话。所以我经历了一段维姆·文德斯电影的迷恋期。
When I'd return my movie, I would kind of linger as if I was kind of looking at the latest new arrivals. And one time she picked up the video, I turned in and I said, hey, you know, are you into Vim Vendors? And she just looked at me like I was speaking a foreign language and was an idiot and went back to her work. Ted was working at the time in a restaurant.
当我归还电影时，我会磨蹭一会儿，好像在看最新的到货影片。有一次她拿起我归还的录像带，我说：“嘿，你喜欢维姆·文德斯吗？”她看着我，就像我在说外语，或者像看个白痴一样，然后就回去工作了。泰德当时在一家餐馆工作。
One day, he happened to have an extra busy shift. And I got into a really good state of just, you know, flowing. When you're working in a restaurant, when you get hit really hard, it's a wonderful feeling. You're part of a team, you know, you know, you're working together, the kitchen and the people out on the floor are all working together to make things happen as quickly as possible. There's no time to think, you know, five hours go by and you don't even notice it.
有一天，他碰巧轮到一个特别忙的班次。我进入了一种非常好的状态，你知道，就是那种“心流”状态。在餐馆工作时，当你忙得不可开交，那是一种美妙的感觉。你是团队的一部分，你知道，大家都在合作，厨房和前厅的人都在齐心协力，尽可能快地完成工作。没有时间去思考，你知道，五个小时就这样过去了，你甚至都没察觉。
And so I had this really intense satisfying shift at the end of it. Uh, I went to the bar bartender knew knew I needed a drink and handed me one. And there just happened to be this really attractive woman sitting at the bar. And without thinking, I just, I don't know what I, I don't even remember what I said, but I just started talking to this person from a place of calm and genuine kind of curiosity
所以在那次非常紧张且令人满足的轮班结束后，我去了吧台，酒保知道我需要喝一杯，就递给我一杯酒。碰巧吧台坐着一位非常有吸引力的女性。我不假思索地——我不知道我说了什么，我甚至不记得我说了什么，但我只是从一种平静和真诚的好奇心出发，开始与那个人交谈，
about the world. So she was an exchange student. She was German, French, Lebanese, very interesting background. And I just wanted to hear about her. What are you doing in San Francisco? What do you study back home? I was just starting to study German.
对这个世界充满好奇。原来她是交换生。她是德国人、法国人、黎巴嫩人，背景非常有趣。我只是想听听她的故事。你在旧金山做什么？你在老家学什么？我当时刚开始学习德语。
So it organically came up that I was studying German philosophy. Oh, that turned into a very long date that evening. And it's interesting, the shift in my life that happened after that, this kind of break in the drought, I don't know if anyone's experienced this, as a single person of it, never rains but it pours. So you go through this long period nothing nothing nothing you finally meet someone and have a great connection great experience
所以很自然地谈到了我正在学习德国哲学。哦，那天晚上那变成了一次非常漫长的约会。有趣的是，在那之后我生活中发生的变化，这种干旱期的结束，我不知道是否有人经历过，作为单身人士，这就像“不雨则已，一雨倾盆”。你经历了一段漫长的什么都没有的时期，终于遇到了一个人，有了很棒的交流和体验，
and then suddenly people just come out of the woodwork so I remember dropping this woman off at the train she was living down the peninsula and going to return a video so I we had watched a Wim Wenders movie because that was my thing and she was German. I walked out of my apartment to go to the video store and within a half block, these two young women walking past me kind of smiled at me. And then about 10 paces on, they turned around and one of them said, hey, my friend wants to date you. And I was like, oh, okay.
然后突然间，人们就纷纷出现了。我记得送那位女士去火车站，她住在半岛那边，然后我去还录像带。我们一起看了维姆·文德斯的电影，因为那是我的爱好，而且她是德国人。我走出公寓去录像带店，在半个街区内，两个路过的年轻女性对我笑了笑。大约走了10步后，她们转过身，其中一个说：“嘿，我朋友想和你约会。”我当时想，哦，好吧。
Well, hi. Out of the blue? Out of the blue is the weirdest thing around and one of them said, hey my friend wants to date you. I was like, oh okay. Out of the blue? Out of the blue is the weirdest thing that's ever happened to me possibly. And I just kind of smiled and waved and went on my way. I got to the video store and dropped my video through the slot as one does and just turned around to leave. And it was that woman who I kept trying to strike up a conversation with. And this time she said, hey, you know, I see you're watching, it was another Vim Vendors movie. What do you like so much about him? And she started talking to me and we had planned to watch a Vim Vendor movie together.
嗯，你好。突如其来？突如其来是最奇怪的事情，其中一个说：“嘿，我朋友想和你约会。”我当时想，哦，好吧。突如其来？这可能是我经历过的最奇怪的事情。我只是笑了笑，挥了挥手，继续走我的路。我到了录像带店，把录像带投进槽里，就像往常一样，然后转身离开。就是那个我一直试图搭话的女士。这次她说：“嘿，我看到你在看，又是维姆·文德斯的电影。你为什么那么喜欢他？”她开始跟我聊天，我们计划一起看一部维姆·文德斯的电影。
So it was just, it was insane. It was like, I actually remember going home and thinking, maybe I shouldn't shower. Like maybe something happened to me, pheromone wise that is, you know, I don't want to mess with. I should keep this shirt on for the next month. But it wasn't pheromones. It was just that I was relaxed and not trying anymore.
所以这太疯狂了。我甚至记得回家时心想，也许我不该洗澡。就像，也许我身上发生了什么费洛蒙方面的变化，你知道，我不想破坏它。我应该在接下来一个月里都穿着这件衬衫。但那不是费洛蒙。只是因为我放松了，不再刻意尝试了。
I want to ask you about something similar that's happened to you more recently, Ted. In this case, it isn't about romance, but tennis. Tell me about your experience of learning to play tennis and your interactions with the tennis pro who sometimes gives you lessons So I learned tennis as an adult and learning a skill like tennis as an adult is like trying to learn a language as an adult it's painful and Takes a lot of time and so I would take lessons and learn the proper form and then my coach would say well now Do all that but in a relaxed way.
我想问你一些最近发生的类似事情，泰德。这次不是关于浪漫，而是关于网球。告诉我你学习打网球的经历，以及你与有时给你上课的网球教练的互动。我是成年后才学网球的，成年后学习像网球这样的技能，就像成年后学习一门语言一样，很痛苦，而且需要很多时间。所以我会上课学习正确的姿势，然后我的教练会说：“好吧，现在做所有这些动作，但要以放松的方式。”
So do all the things I've consciously told you, but now stop thinking consciously about it. And it was really hard to do. And it was only typically when we kind of stopped the official lesson and just be hitting around at the end that I would suddenly feel what it feels like to not try and to just hit the ball. And I've experienced this as well more recently. I started playing tennis with a colleague of mine
所以，做所有我刻意告诉你的动作，但现在停止有意识地去想它。这真的很难做到。通常只有当我们结束正式课程，在最后随便打打时，我才会突然感觉到不刻意去尝试、只是击球是什么感觉。最近我也经历过这种情况。我开始和我的同事一起打网球，
here at UBC, he's a psychologist, Liz Dunn. And so Liz coined this term that I still use and I think that is now a meme going through the Vancouver tennis community. But we would play and we both knew we weren't being relaxed And I think that is now a meme going through the Vancouver tennis community. But we would play and we both knew we weren't being relaxed and hitting the right way. And after we finished our match, I remember when she said, let's do danger tennis. And I was like, what's danger tennis?
在UBC这里，她是心理学家，莉兹·邓恩。莉兹创造了一个我至今仍在使用的术语，我认为它现在已经成了温哥华网球圈的一个梗。我们会打球，我们都知道我们并没有放松，也没有用正确的方式击球。在比赛结束后，我记得她说：“我们来玩‘危险网球’吧。”我问：“什么是危险网球？”
And she said, we're just going to hit the ball as hard as we can. And we don't care if it goes in. Let's just hit the ball. And suddenly we were killing it. It was going in and we were hitting really well. And so I've done this where, you know, I've played matches with guys and we're both kind of a little tense and we're not hitting right.
她说：“我们只是尽可能用力地击球。我们不在乎球是否会出界。我们就只是击球。”突然间，我们打得非常出色。球都进了，我们打得非常好。所以我做过这种尝试，你知道，我和其他人打比赛，我们俩都有点紧张，打得不对。
And then I say, let's play danger tennis. And suddenly we're killing it. And everyone I do this with says, okay, I'm gonna just play danger tennis all the time. But as soon as there are stakes, as soon as we're keeping score, our conscious mind pops up and interferes with our performance.
然后我说：“我们来玩危险网球吧。”突然间我们打得非常棒。每个和我玩过的人都说：“好吧，我以后要一直玩危险网球。”但只要有赌注，只要我们开始记分，我们的意识就会跳出来干扰我们的表现。
You tell a story about visiting a local science museum that features a game called Mindball. What is Mindball, Ted? So it's a very cleverly set up game. You've got two people at either side of a long table and there's a metal ball in the middle and the goal is to push that ball to the other end of the table and if you do it falls into a little hole and an alarm goes off and you win it's very exciting. The trick is that you're not pushing the ball with your hand, you're using your mind.
你讲过一个参观当地科学博物馆的故事，那里有一个叫“意念球”（Mindball）的游戏。什么是意念球，泰德？这是一个设计非常巧妙的游戏。长桌两端各坐一个人，中间有一个金属球，目标是把球推到桌子的另一端。如果你做到了，球会掉进一个小洞里，警报响起，你就赢了，非常刺激。诀窍在于你不是用手推球，而是用你的大脑。
So both players have a net on their heads, an EEG monitor. And this EEG monitor is picking up alpha and theta waves. So this is the kind of signature brain activity that you kick off when you're relaxed, when you're not trying, when you're not thinking too much, when you're not exerting effort, you kick off more alpha and theta waves. The way the game is set up is the more alpha and theta waves you produce, the more force you exert on the ball. So the way to win at mind ball is to not try to win. And it's fiendishly difficult to do. So the first time I played, I put on the net, I closed my eyes, I relaxed, and you could hear the ball moving around, but I couldn't see where it was. And finally I opened my eyes and I was winning. The ball was most of the way toward the
所以两名玩家头上都戴着网罩，这是一个脑电图（EEG）监测器。这个监测器在捕捉阿尔法波和西塔波。这是当你放松、不刻意尝试、不思考太多、不费力时，大脑发出的标志性活动。你越放松，发出的阿尔法波和西塔波就越多。游戏的设置是，你产生的阿尔法波和西塔波越多，你对球施加的力就越大。所以赢得意念球的方法就是不要试图去赢。这极其困难。我第一次玩的时候，戴上网罩，闭上眼睛，放松下来，你可以听到球在移动，但我看不见它在哪里。最后我睁开眼睛，我赢了。球已经到了桌子的
other end of the table. And I thought, oh, I'm winning, I'm good at this. And as soon as I thought that the ball stopped, it was like it could read my mind and started rolling back toward me. And then I started panicking, I was like, relax, relax. And that of course just made it worse. And you know, I lost terribly. So I was playing with a neuroscientist who runs this exhibit and she completely crushed me.
另一端。我想：“哦，我赢了，我很擅长这个。”我刚这么一想，球就停了，就像它能读懂我的心思一样，开始滚回我这边。然后我开始恐慌，我想：“放松，放松。”当然，这只会让情况更糟。你知道，我输得很惨。所以我当时是在和一个负责这个展览的神经科学家一起玩，她完全碾压了我。
And she said afterwards, her strategy, she just knows that you can't look, you can't care. She would just go into this zone where she would think about a vacation that she had on a beach that she really enjoyed once. But what I love about mind ball is it compresses into the smallest possible space, this tension. You know that the only way to win is to relax.
事后她说，她的策略是，她知道你不能看，你不能在意。她会进入一种状态，去想她曾经在海滩上享受过的一次假期。但我喜欢意念球的原因是，它将这种张力压缩到了最小的空间里。你知道唯一的获胜方法就是放松。
But consciously trying to relax is impossible. Ted had discovered something that many of us have also found. Sometimes the best way to get something is to stop trying to get it. When we come back, the science of why effort can sometimes backfire. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Edward Slingelin is a professor of philosophy at the University of British Columbia. He's the author of Trying Not to Try, Ancient China, Modern Science, and the power of spontaneity. Ted, social scientists often say the human mind operates in two modes, system one or system two.
但有意识地试图放松是不可能的。泰德发现了一些我们许多人也发现的事情。有时获得某样东西的最好方法就是停止试图去获得它。回来后，我们将探讨为什么努力有时会适得其反。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。爱德华·斯林格林是不列颠哥伦比亚大学的哲学教授。他是《试图不去尝试：古代中国、现代科学与自发性的力量》一书的作者。泰德，社会科学家常说人类思维以两种模式运作，系统一或系统二。
What are these two systems? How do they work? So system one is sometimes called hot cognition. These are all the automatic processes that we are running all the time. And the vast majority of human cognition is hot. When we are walking down the street, when we're picking up a glass, we're not consciously thinking about how to do this. So those are the hot systems.
这两种系统是什么？它们是如何运作的？系统一有时被称为“热认知”。这些是我们一直在运行的所有自动过程。绝大多数人类认知都是“热”的。当我们走在街上，当我们拿起杯子时，我们并没有有意识地思考如何做这些事。所以这些就是“热”系统。
System two or cold cognition, it's conscious, it's effortful, it takes time, it's slow. And this is when we're consciously thinking about something or we're trying to stop a hot process that we don't want to do, we want to turn it into something else. So these two systems work together, but most of what's going on is that that hot system one cognition. So psychologists like Daniel Kahneman, who wrote the book Thinking Fast and Slow, they've argued that the cool-headed system too, with its careful cognition, can save us from the errors and biases of the hot-headed system one.
系统二或“冷认知”，它是意识性的，费力的，需要时间，很慢。这是当我们有意识地思考某事，或者试图停止我们不想做的“热”过程，想把它变成别的东西时。所以这两个系统协同工作，但大部分发生的事情都是那种“热”的系统一认知。所以像丹尼尔·卡尼曼（《思考，快与慢》的作者）这样的心理学家认为，冷静的系统二及其谨慎的认知可以拯救我们免受热血系统一的错误和偏见的影响。
Would you agree with that thesis, Ted? In certain contexts, it's certainly the case that the hot system leads us astray. And so Kahneman Tversky did a lot of work on how we need our cold cognition to fix our hot systems or just override them completely. And so the early work on this, I think, tended to overlook the importance of hot cognition. As a general rule, society constantly tells us we should tamp down our intuitive, automatic
你同意这个论点吗，泰德？在某些情况下，确实是“热”系统引导我们走入歧途。所以卡尼曼和特沃斯基做了大量工作，研究我们如何需要冷认知来修复热系统，或者完全覆盖它们。所以我认为，关于这一点的早期研究往往忽视了热认知的重要性。作为一般规则，社会不断告诉我们，我们应该抑制直觉的、自动的
thinking, our hidden brain if you will, and prioritize effortful, deliberate, analytical thinking. Schools teach us to think before we act. Workplaces encourage us to filter what we say. The rules of social interaction highlight the importance of courtesy, politeness, and social norms. politeness, and social norms. Over time, many of us get very good at these skills. So good, in fact, that we find it difficult to turn off logical, deliberate, effortful thinking. That's useful in a boardroom, but turns out to be a liability when you're trying,
思维——也就是你的“隐藏大脑”，并优先考虑费力的、审慎的、分析性的思维。学校教我们三思而后行。工作场所鼓励我们过滤言论。社交规则强调礼貌、客气和社交规范的重要性。随着时间的推移，我们许多人变得非常擅长这些技能。事实上，好到我们发现很难关闭逻辑的、审慎的、费力的思维。这在董事会里很有用，但当你试图
say, to put yourself to sleep. So you are tossing and turning, you have a big meeting tomorrow or just worried about something, and you need to shut your conscious mind down. And so you tell yourself, relax, relax. The problem is the part of your brain that you're trying to shut down is in fact the part you're activating when you're trying. This is why insomnia is very difficult to get around, especially when the thing preventing you from sleeping is your mind that you need to shut down. People come up with various strategies to get around this, counting sheep or paying
比如，让自己入睡时，它就成了负担。你辗转反侧，明天有个重要会议，或者只是担心某事，你需要关闭你的意识。所以你告诉自己：“放松，放松。”问题是，你试图关闭的那部分大脑，实际上正是你在尝试时所激活的那部分。这就是为什么失眠很难解决，尤其是当阻止你入睡的东西正是你需要关闭的大脑时。人们想出各种策略来解决这个问题，数羊或者关注
attention to your breath. If there was a really easy solution to this, we would all know about it. Same thing with tennis. I mean, I know that I'm most effective at tennis when I'm relaxed and just not caring. And yet if I double fault, I get all tense and annoyed at myself.
你的呼吸。如果有一个非常简单的解决方案，我们都会知道。网球也是一样。我的意思是，我知道我在打网球时最有效率的时候是我放松且不在乎的时候。然而，如果我双误了，我会变得非常紧张，对自己感到恼火。
And part of my brain, the scholarly part of my brain is like, hey, dude, this is a try not to try situation, relax. And yet you can know that consciously and it doesn't really help you. So you're a fan of the great tennis player Roger Federer and you've asked yourself what would happen in a game if an athlete like Federer started thinking too much. Do you think that even at the elite level when players start to think about what they're doing it can get in the way of their game? Especially at the elite level.
我大脑的一部分，学术的那部分，会说：“嘿，伙计，这是一个‘试图不去尝试’的情况，放松。”然而，你可以有意识地知道这一点，但这并不能真正帮助你。所以你是伟大的网球运动员罗杰·费德勒的粉丝，你问过自己，如果像费德勒这样的运动员开始想得太多，比赛会发生什么？你认为即使在精英水平，当球员开始思考他们在做什么时，也会阻碍他们的比赛吗？尤其是在精英水平。
So there's a huge literature on this. I mean, at high level tennis, these are people who've been playing since they were kids. They've completely mastered these skills. And it's entirely a mind game at that level of tennis. It's all about really who can out relax the other person. And supposedly, I don't know if this is a myth, but John McEnroe is kind of not the nicest tennis player
关于这一点有大量的文献。我的意思是，在高水平网球比赛中，这些人是从小就开始打球的。他们已经完全掌握了这些技能。在那个水平的网球比赛中，这完全是一场心理游戏。这完全取决于谁能比对方更放松。据说——我不知道这是否是神话——约翰·麦肯罗并不是世界上最友好的网球运动员，
in the world, and he apparently took advantage of this. So the rumor is that if he was playing someone and their serve was really great, when they changed sides and he was walking by them, he'd say, hey, hey, your serves really great today. What are you, are you doing something different? And you get in their heads and they start thinking about it. They're like, am I doing something different?
他显然利用了这一点。传闻说，如果他在和某人比赛，对方的发球非常棒，当他们换边走过他身边时，他会说：“嘿，嘿，你今天的发球真棒。你是在做什么不同的动作吗？”你进入了他们的脑子，他们开始思考这个问题。他们会想：“我是在做不同的动作吗？”
Wait a minute. And then they couldn't serve anymore. So the great jazz musician Charlie Parker was a believer in going with the flow. And I'm wondering if if music, especially music that is improvised, might be another domain where overthinking can lead to problems. People in sports and music and performance, they're obsessed with this because they know
“等一下。”然后他们就再也发不出好球了。所以伟大的爵士音乐家查理·帕克是“顺其自然”的信徒。我想知道，如果音乐，尤其是即兴创作的音乐，可能是另一个过度思考会导致问题的领域。体育、音乐和表演领域的人对此非常着迷，因为他们知道
that the only way to do certain things well is to relax into them. So if it works well, it's only because everyone's kind of given up really trying to drive it themselves. They're just listening intensely and they kind of know, like the piano knows when it's time to take over and when it's time to give it up. And it's this very delicate dance that only works if everyone's relaxed, everyone's genuinely involved, and no one's interposing their ego into the process.
做好某些事情的唯一方法就是放松地融入其中。所以如果它运作良好，那只是因为每个人都放弃了真正试图去掌控它。他们只是在专注地倾听，他们知道，就像钢琴知道什么时候该接管，什么时候该放弃。这是一种非常微妙的舞蹈，只有在每个人都放松、每个人都真诚投入、没有人把自我强加到过程中时，它才会奏效。
You know, Charlie Parker is supposed to have once said, don't play the saxophone, let it play you, which is of course probably easier said than done. But I can easily imagine the same thing being true in, you know, stand up comedy or acting if you're in the theater. You know, if you're too conscious about what it is that you're doing, presumably it's going to get in the way of your interpretation of the character. Absolutely. So people in improv are obsessed with this problem, right? Because improv, you're out there without a net and you, you know, you don't know necessarily what you're doing. The only way to do it well is to really get absorbed,
你知道，查理·帕克曾经说过：“不要演奏萨克斯，让它演奏你。”这当然说起来容易做起来难。但我可以很容易地想象同样的事情在单口喜剧或表演中也是如此。你知道，如果你对自己在做什么太有意识，大概会阻碍你对角色的诠释。绝对是这样。所以即兴表演的人对这个问题很着迷，对吧？因为即兴表演，你是在没有保护网的情况下，你不知道自己到底在做什么。做好它的唯一方法就是真正沉浸其中，
to really let your partners drive it, to not try to be funny, let funniness happen. So it's kind of let the saxophone play you, you have to let the jokes play you, you have to let the situation dictate what your next step is. I understand that you encountered this tension in your early 30s when you were trying to learn to dance the salsa. Tell me about that, Ted.
真正让你的搭档去引导，不要试图去搞笑，让幽默自然发生。所以这就像“让萨克斯演奏你”，你必须让笑话演奏你，你必须让情况决定你的下一步。我知道你在30岁出头尝试学习跳萨尔萨舞时遇到了这种张力。告诉我那件事，泰德。
What happened? Oh, God. That was terrible. I just couldn't do it. And I was taking these lessons with this instructor who got really annoyed with me and she kept saying, "'Just relax, you're thinking too much.'" And the more she told me to relax, the tenser I got,
发生了什么？哦，天哪。那太糟糕了。我就是做不到。我跟着那个教练上课，她对我非常恼火，她一直说：“放松点，你想得太多了。”她越是让我放松，我就越紧张，
it just was this terrible vicious circle. So dancing, anything where to be successful, you have to surrender to some extent. And to dance well, you can't be thinking about the steps, you can't be thinking about what you look like. You can't be thinking about anything at all really. You need to just let the music move your body and you have to surrender.
那简直是一个可怕的恶性循环。所以跳舞，任何想要成功就必须在某种程度上投降的事情。要跳好舞，你不能去想舞步，你不能去想你看起来怎么样。你真的什么都不能想。你需要让音乐带动你的身体，你必须投降。
move your body and you have to surrender. And this instructor constantly telling me to relax made it impossible for me to do that. Yeah. I mean I think the challenge here is that there are situations where we care so much about the outcome that it's really difficult to in effect not care about the outcome that it's really difficult to in effect not care about the outcome. I'm thinking about job interviews or first dates. These are situations that carry enormous weight. People care about the outcomes of what happens
教练不断地让我放松，这让我根本无法做到。是的。我的意思是，这里的挑战在于，有些情况下我们太在意结果，以至于很难做到“不在意结果”。我想到的是求职面试或第一次约会。这些情况承载着巨大的分量。人们在意发生的结果，
and of course, trying too hard in these situations can convey an unappealing feeling of desperation. Yeah, no, it's like trying to get a date. It's like the difference between match play and danger tennis. When you care about the outcome, when you're attached to use the language of the Bhagavad Gita, when you're attached to the fruits, you're not going to be in a state of effortless action because you care too much about the goal instead of allowing going to be in a state of effortless action because you're just trying you care too much about the the goal Instead of allowing yourself to be absorbed in the process
当然，在这些情况下用力过猛会传达出一种令人不悦的绝望感。是的，这就像试图去约会。这就像比赛和“危险网球”之间的区别。当你关心结果时，当你——用《薄伽梵歌》的语言来说——当你执着于果报时，你就不会处于一种不费力的行动状态，因为你太在意目标，而不是让自己沉浸在过程中。
And and how you turn that off is really at the center of this tension of how you can try not to try You know one domain I think we all are in some ways familiar with, where we see people sometimes trying too hard, is in the domain of politics. Politicians need to come across as spontaneous, they need to come across as authentic, but sometimes when they come across as controlled or effortful, they can come across as being untrustworthy or unappealing. I want to play you a clip here of someone who ran for president of the United States a few years ago.
而你如何关闭它，确实是“试图不去尝试”这种张力的核心。你知道，我认为我们都在某种程度上熟悉的一个领域，就是政治。政治家需要表现得自发，需要表现得真实，但有时当他们表现得受控或费力时，他们会显得不可信或没有吸引力。我想给你放一段几年前竞选美国总统的人的片段。
I think the next president needs to be a lot quieter, but send a signal that we're prepared to act in the national security interests of this country to get back in the business of creating a more peaceful world. Please clap. So that's a clip of former Florida Governor Jeb Bush. What do you hear in that clip, Ted? I hear a stand-up comic asking his audience to please laugh. Please laugh at that joke. And so in politics, you really see this tension where you could have someone who's incredibly qualified.
“我认为下一任总统需要安静得多，但要发出信号，表明我们准备好为了国家的国家安全利益采取行动，重新开始创造一个更和平的世界。请鼓掌。”那是前佛罗里达州州长杰布·布什的片段。你在那段片段里听到了什么，泰德？我听到一个单口喜剧演员要求观众“请笑”。请为那个笑话笑一笑。所以在政治中，你真的看到了这种张力，你可能有一个非常有资格的人。
They actually probably would be a great leader, but they have problems relaxing and conveying that to ordinary people. I think this was the problem with Hillary Clinton is that she did not come off as relaxed and authentic. And I think it's a real danger in politics right now. I mean, Donald Trump, the guy just, whatever kind of pops into his head comes out of his mouth.
他们实际上可能是一位伟大的领导者，但他们很难放松并向普通民众传达这一点。我认为这就是希拉里·克林顿的问题，她表现得不够放松和真实。我认为这在现在的政治中是一个真正的危险。我的意思是，唐纳德·特朗普，那个人，无论脑子里冒出什么，都会脱口而出。
And I think that's a real part of his appeal is people have the sense that he is authentic. And there's a kind of charisma that comes with not having a filter, with really just being who you are that people seem to find appealing. So modern psychology has begun to explore the idea that in some domains our thinking can trip us up and get in the way of what we actually want to accomplish. The late great psychologist Daniel Wagner studied how difficult it was to think our
我认为这是他吸引力的一部分，人们觉得他是真实的。有一种魅力来自于没有过滤器，真正做你自己，人们似乎觉得这很有吸引力。所以现代心理学已经开始探索这样一个想法：在某些领域，我们的思维会绊倒我们，阻碍我们真正想要完成的事情。已故的伟大心理学家丹尼尔·韦格纳研究了通过思考来达到自发性是多么困难。告诉我他的想法，泰德。
way to spontaneity. Tell me about his ideas, Ted. Well, he has this great experiment where he asked people to not, he said, don't think of a white bear. And if you say that to someone, they will think of a white bear. His point was there's this paradoxical situation where you're activating the very concept you're trying to shut down. And I learned about his work when I was writing Try Not to Try because it's basically around, it's about the same problem. This paradoxical fact that when it
嗯，他有一个很棒的实验，他让人们不要——他说：“不要去想一只白熊。”如果你对某人这么说，他们就会去想一只白熊。他的观点是，存在一种悖论情况，你激活了你试图关闭的那个概念。我在写《试图不去尝试》时了解了他的工作，因为它基本上是围绕着同一个问题。这个悖论事实是，当涉及到自发性时，如果你试图去实现它，它就不会奏效。努力与你试图实现的目标之间存在这种悖论关系。
comes to spontaneity, if you are trying to achieve it, it's not going to work. And there's this paradoxical relationship between effort and the goal that you're trying to achieve. I understand that in another experiment he asked people to putt a golf ball and he found that if you told people try to get it in the hole, but whatever you do, don't overshoot the whole. People systematically began to overshoot the whole a lot more than if you didn't give them that instruction. Again, in some ways, it's sort of the paradox of trying to put yourself to sleep. And the more you try, the less you're able to sleep.
我知道在另一个实验中，他让人们推高尔夫球，他发现如果你告诉人们：“试着把它推进洞里，但无论你做什么，都不要推过头。”人们系统性地开始比不给他们那个指令时更多地推过头。同样，在某种程度上，这有点像试图让自己入睡的悖论。你越努力，你就越无法入睡。
The more you try and do something perfectly, the less well it sometimes turns out. Yeah, his work was an important corrective, I think, to this idea that more effort is always good. If you're not being successful in something, just put some more effort into it. Try harder. And that does work in some domains where just cranking it out is going to get you results.
你越努力想把事情做得完美，结果有时就越糟糕。是的，他的工作是一个重要的纠正，我认为，纠正了那种“更多的努力总是好的”的想法。如果你在某件事上不成功，那就多投入一点努力。更努力地尝试。这在某些领域确实有效，只要投入就能得到结果。
But there are a lot of domains where that's not the case. And I think Dan Wagner did a great job of showing how there are certain lot of domains where that's not the case. And I think Dan Wegner did a great job of showing how there are certain types of human goals that just can't be directly attacked. It's like the butterfly of happiness. If you try to capture it, it flutters away. You need to just let it come and sit in your hand. And I don't think as a culture,
但有很多领域并非如此。我认为丹·韦格纳很好地展示了人类的某些目标是无法直接攻击的。这就像幸福的蝴蝶。如果你试图捕捉它，它就会飞走。你需要让它自己飞过来停在你的手上。我不认为作为一个文化，
we pay enough attention to the fact that there are really important goals in life that we're going to ruin if we try to attack them directly. Thinking is a human superpower. It has helped us become the dominant species on the planet. On a daily basis, thinking and planning and effort bring us innumerable benefits. But like all aspects of human behavior, you can sometimes get too much of a good thing. a good thing. When we come back, techniques to stop overthinking. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta.
我们足够关注这样一个事实：生活中确实存在一些重要的目标，如果我们试图直接攻击它们，就会毁掉它们。思考是人类的超能力。它帮助我们成为地球上的主导物种。每天，思考、计划和努力都给我们带来了无数的好处。但像人类行为的所有方面一样，有时好事也会过头。回来后，我们将探讨停止过度思考的技术。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
We often believe the key to success is to relentlessly pursue our goals. Grit, determination and drive are indeed powerful tools to achieving success, but there are many domains in life where these tools are not just ineffective, but actually counterproductive. Edward Slingerlin is a professor of philosophy at the University of British Columbia. He's the author of Trying Not to Try Ancient, modern science, and the power of spontaneity. Ted, early on in your study of philosophy, you encountered a passage written by the Enlightenment philosopher Immanuel Kant that made you think that Western philosophy had taken a wrong
我们常认为成功的关键是不断追求我们的目标。毅力、决心和干劲确实是实现成功的强大工具，但生活中有很多领域，这些工具不仅无效，而且实际上适得其反。爱德华·斯林格林是不列颠哥伦比亚大学的哲学教授。他是《试图不去尝试：古代中国、现代科学与自发性的力量》一书的作者。泰德，在你研究哲学的早期，你读到过启蒙哲学家伊曼努尔·康德写的一段话，让你觉得西方哲学在某个地方走错了
turn somewhere. Tell me what you read and how it struck you. There's a passage in the groundwork of the metaphysics of morals where Kant is talking about what he calls, I think, the amiable person who is just good-natured and warm. And they help other people just out of the goodness of their heart. They don't really think about it. They see someone in need, they help them out. Kant says this person's okay, but their behavior is not properly moral.
方向。告诉我你读到了什么，它给你留下了什么印象。在《道德形而上学奠基》中有一段话，康德谈到了他所说的，我想是“和蔼的人”，他们天性善良、温暖。他们帮助别人只是出于内心的善良。他们并没有真正去思考。他们看到有人需要帮助，就伸出援手。康德说这个人还可以，但他们的行为不是真正的道德。
Because for a Kant, for an action to really be moral, it has to be consciously chosen. You have to stop and you have to think, what does the categorical imperative say I should do? Then you need to do it because the categorical imperative says you should do it. So if you want to use that language of hot and cold, Kant believed that hot cognition had no moral qualities to it and true morality had to spring solely from cold cognition or through conscious choice. I remember reading that and just thinking it was nuts.
因为对康德来说，一个行为要真正具有道德，它必须是有意识选择的。你必须停下来思考：“绝对命令说我应该做什么？”然后你需要去做，因为绝对命令说你应该这样做。所以如果你想使用“热”和“冷”的语言，康德认为热认知没有任何道德品质，真正的道德必须完全源于冷认知或有意识的选择。我记得读到那段话时，只觉得它疯了。
Like if I had, there are two people and one of them helps me because they're amiable, they see that I'm in need and they want to help me. And the other person looks at me and says, okay, it's a catechorical imperative to say that I should help this person. Yes, I'll go help them. I want the first person as my neighbor. I don't want to deal with help this person. Yes, I'll go help them. I don't want the first person as my neighbor. I don't want to deal with the second person. So, I mean, I understand his motivations.
如果我有两个人，其中一个帮助我是因为他们和蔼，他们看到我有需要，他们想帮助我。而另一个人看着我说：“好吧，绝对命令说我应该帮助这个人。是的，我去帮他们。”我想要第一个人做我的邻居。我不想处理第二个人的那种帮助。所以，我的意思是，我理解他的动机。
He was very worried about the variability of hot cognition and how it can lead us astray and all the kinds of things that people like Kahneman and Tversky were worried about. But I think he missed the fact that we need warmth. We need hot cognition and morality. So that kind of turned me off on Western philosophy and sent me down a different path. You know, I'm reminded of something that the Lebanese-American poet Khalil Gibran once
他非常担心热认知的多变性，以及它如何导致我们走入歧途，以及像卡尼曼和特沃斯基所担心的所有事情。但我认为他忽略了一个事实，即我们需要温暖。我们需要热认知和道德。所以这让我对西方哲学失去了兴趣，并让我走上了一条不同的道路。你知道，我想起了黎巴嫩裔美国诗人纪伯伦曾经
said. In one of his poems, he wrote, There are those who give with joy, and that joy is their reward, and there are those who give with pain, and that pain is their baptism. And there are those who give, and know not pain in giving, nor do they seek joy, nor give with mindfulness or virtue, they give as in yonder valley the myrtle breathes its fragrance into space. Through the hands of such as these God speaks, and from behind their eyes, he smiles upon
说过的话。在他的一首诗中，他写道：“有些人怀着喜悦给予，那喜悦就是他们的报酬；有些人怀着痛苦给予，那痛苦就是他们的洗礼。还有些人给予，在给予中不知痛苦，也不寻求喜悦，也不怀着正念或美德给予，他们给予，就像远方山谷里的桃金娘将芬芳散入空间。通过这样的人的手，上帝在说话，从他们的眼睛后面，他微笑着注视着大地。”当然，那是诗歌，泰德，不是科学，但它确实触及了同一个想法，即不假思索的慷慨实际上是最好的慷慨，恰恰因为它自发且不假思索。那太美了。是的。所以这就是我进入中国哲学的原因。所以我在研究生院研究的早期中国思想家，实际上对康德的评价正好相反。在其中一位思想家荀子（早期儒家）的著作中，有一段非常有趣的段落，他给道德人排了序。
the earth." Now, of course, that's poetry, Ted, not science, but it does get at the same idea that unthinking generosity is in fact the best form of generosity, precisely because it's spontaneous and unthinking. That's beautiful. Yeah. So that's very much why I got into Chinese philosophy. So the early Chinese thinkers that I came to study in graduate school have actually the opposite ranking of Kant. So there's actually a very interesting passage in one of these thinkers named Schoenze, early Confucian, where he ranks moral people.
道德的最低层次是康德阶段。就是当你了解礼仪的要求，你并不真正想做，但你强迫自己去做，因为礼仪是这样说的。荀子说，真正的圣人是那种以道德方式行事的人，就像你跳舞时真正跳好舞时对音乐的投降，或者你只是自发地放松融入你的环境，那是真正的道德，那是真正的儒家圣人。所以他们的评价与我们在西方启蒙思想中看到的正好相反，
And the lowest level of being moral is the Kantian stage. It's when you kind of know what ritual demands and you don't really feel like doing it, but you force yourself to do it because ritual says so. And Shunzo says if the true sage is someone who acts in a moral fashion in the way you surrender to the music of a dance when you're really dancing properly or you just are spontaneously relaxing into your environment, that's true morality and that's a true Confucian sage. So they have really the opposite valuation that we see in Western Enlightenment thinking
那是我们应该努力追求的。所以你说许多早期中国哲学家专注于努力与自发性之间的问题，许多思想家使用了一个术语叫“无为”。什么是“无为”？它意味着什么，泰德？它字面意思是“不做”或“不努力”。我把它翻译为“不费力的行动”。这是一种状态，就像运动员进入“心流”一样。这是一种你失去了作为代理人的自我感的状态。你失去了时间流逝的感觉。你沉浸在你正在做的事情中。你没有去想结果。这就是不费力的行动。它是源于……的行动。
that we should be striving for. So you say that many early Chinese philosophers were preoccupied with the question of effort versus spontaneity, And many of these thinkers used a term called ouwe. What is ouwe? What does it mean, Ted? It literally means no doing or no striving. I translated it as effortless action. And it's a state, something like being in the zone as an athlete. It's a state where you lose a sense of yourself as an agent. You lose a sense of the passage of time. You get absorbed into what you're doing. You're not thinking about the results. That's effortless action. It's action that springs
我们应该努力追求的目标。所以你说许多早期中国哲学家都专注于努力与自发性之间的问题，而许多思想家使用了一个叫“无为”的术语。什么是“无为”？泰德，它是什么意思？它字面意思是“不做”或“不努力”。我把它翻译为“无为而为”。这是一种状态，类似于运动员进入“心流”状态。在这种状态下，你失去了作为行动者的自我意识，失去了对时间流逝的感觉，完全沉浸在所做的事情中。你不再考虑结果。这就是“无为而为”。这是一种源于自然的行动。
in a kind of spontaneous, natural way. And in modern terms, we would say it's a state where your system to your cold cognition is not really involved. Now this sounds a lot like the modern concept of flow, which was introduced by the psychologist Mihaly Csikszentmihalyi, which is that you lose yourself in the thing that you're doing, and as you extend effort, as you're doing this difficult thing, you sort of forget, you know, the passage of time. Hours go by, and you feel like only minutes have gone by. Is there a connection here between those two ideas?
以一种自发、自然的方式。用现代术语来说，我们会说这是一种你的系统与冷认知（cold cognition）并不真正参与的状态。这听起来很像心理学家米哈里·契克森米哈赖提出的现代概念——“心流”（flow），即你沉浸在所做的事情中，当你付出努力，做着这件困难的事情时，你似乎忘记了时间的流逝。几个小时过去了，你却觉得只过了几分钟。这两个概念之间有什么联系吗？
Very much so. But the concept of wu-wei is more expansive and helpful than the concept of flow, in the sense that Chicks Mihai had a problem where he wanted to distinguish flow states from just sitting in front of the TV, fetching out or scrolling through Twitter or whatever. We have these experiences that on the surface seem like flow states.
非常有联系。但“无为”的概念比“心流”的概念更广阔、更有帮助，因为契克森米哈赖遇到了一个问题，他想把心流状态与仅仅坐在电视机前、发呆或刷推特等行为区分开来。我们确实有一些表面上看起来像心流状态的体验。
So they have some of the hallmarks. We lose a sense of the passage of time. We kind of lose a sense of ourself. We get absorbed. But we come out of it feeling crummy, like we feel dirty or like we wasted our time. So he doesn't want to call those states flow. And what he settled on was this idea
它们具备一些心流的特征。我们失去了对时间流逝的感觉。我们似乎失去了自我意识。我们变得全神贯注。但当我们从中走出来时，感觉很糟糕，就像觉得肮脏或者浪费了时间。所以他不想把这些状态称为心流。他最终确定的是这个概念
of complexity and challenge. So he argues that what distinguishes flow states is that they're just the right level of complexity and challenge. So he argues that what distinguishes flow states is that they're just the right level of complexity to challenge your skill level. This fits certain flow states. So it fits rock climbing, it fits sports, but I think that his definition is too narrow. And so this is where I find the early Chinese concept more helpful.
即复杂性和挑战性。因此他认为，心流状态的区别在于它们处于复杂性和挑战性的最佳水平。所以他认为，心流状态的区别在于它们处于与你的技能水平相匹配的恰当复杂性水平。这适用于某些心流状态。它适用于攀岩、体育运动，但我认为他的定义太狭隘了。这就是我觉得早期中国概念更有帮助的地方。
So the early Chinese would argue, that's what is distinctive of an wu-wei experience, is two parts. You've become absorbed into something that's bigger than you. So you're absorbed into something larger than the narrow ego. It's something that you care about. And this that explains playing with kids. You know, you love being with kids and you get absorbed in the game. So I think it's a better definition because it captures the full spectrum of where we get into these away flow states. So many of these early Chinese thinkers believe that a person in an ui state radiated a certain
所以早期中国人会认为，无为体验的独特之处在于两部分。你融入了比你自身更宏大的事物中。所以你融入了比狭隘的自我更宏大的事物。那是你在乎的东西。这解释了为什么和孩子一起玩耍时会有这种感觉。你知道，你喜欢和孩子们在一起，并沉浸在游戏中。所以我认为这是一个更好的定义，因为它捕捉到了我们进入这些无为心流状态的全貌。许多早期中国思想家认为，处于无为状态的人会散发出一种
quality. What was this quality, Ted? So unfortunately in modern Mandarin it's pronounced duh, which my students sometimes giggle about. If I have to translate it, I would do it as charismatic power. And if you're a Confucian and you have duh, people want to follow you. They want to obey you. They want to be part of your government. And you don't have to force them to do it. If you're a Taoist, it's the power that allows
特质。泰德，这种特质是什么？不幸的是，在现代普通话中它读作“德”（dé），我的学生有时会为此窃笑。如果非要翻译，我会把它译为“魅力力量”（charismatic power）。如果你是儒家信徒并且拥有“德”，人们会想要追随你。他们想要服从你。他们想要成为你政府的一部分。而你不需要强迫他们这样做。如果你是道家信徒，这是一种力量，它允许
you to relax everyone and get them to be natural instead of being unnatural as they are now. So it's this power you have to affect other people. And in the early Chinese context, if you're in the state of wu wei, you're in harmony with heaven. From a modern perspective, we can give a naturalistic interpretation of this connection between spontaneity and charisma. And the connection is everything we just talked about in the first segment. Why you can't get a date when you're trying hard, why politicians who seem to be trying too hard are unappealing to people. Human beings are superbly attuned bulls**t detectors. We're constantly evaluating the sincerity and authenticity of the people we're interacting with.
你让每个人都放松下来，让他们变得自然，而不是像现在这样不自然。所以这是一种你影响他人的力量。在早期中国的语境下，如果你处于无为状态，你就与天道和谐一致。从现代视角来看，我们可以对这种自发性与魅力之间的联系做出自然主义的解释。这种联系就是我们在第一部分讨论的所有内容。为什么当你刻意追求时反而找不到对象，为什么那些看起来用力过猛的政客对人们没有吸引力。人类是极其敏锐的“胡扯探测器”。我们不断地评估与我们互动的人的真诚度和真实性。
And we're built in such a way that we're attracted to people who are relaxed, people who seem confident, people who don't seem to have ulterior motives. When I'm trying to insert myself in a conversation at a party, I don't have to, no one wants to talk to me. When I'm just relaxed and tired out after a long shift at work that went well, I'm in a state of wu-wei and I have this power of duh. So I think we can tell a very compelling cognitive scientific story that humans associate spontaneity with trustworthiness. So besides the value of understanding how the ancient Chinese thinkers thought, that's interesting and valuable for its own sake, you argue that thinking about these terms
我们的天性使我们被那些放松、自信、看起来没有不可告人动机的人所吸引。当我在聚会上试图强行加入谈话时，没人想和我说话。当我工作了一整天后感到放松和疲惫，处于无为状态时，我就拥有了这种“德”的力量。所以我认为我们可以讲述一个非常有说服力的认知科学故事，即人类将自发性与可信度联系在一起。所以，除了理解中国古代思想家如何思考的价值（这本身就很有趣且有价值）之外，你认为思考这些术语
in everyday life can also be useful, that in some ways, knowing the terms and understanding what they mean actually transforms many of the things that we do. And you, in fact, use these terms in your daily life. You and your friends and colleagues actually deploy these terms, and when you deploy them, you find that it changes your relationship to the things that you're doing.
在日常生活中也很有用，在某种程度上，了解这些术语并理解它们的含义实际上改变了我们所做的许多事情。事实上，你在日常生活中也使用这些术语。你和你的朋友、同事实际上都在运用这些术语，当你运用它们时，你会发现它改变了你与所做事情之间的关系。
Words are very helpful in pointing out gaps in our knowledge. So, everyone experiences Schadenfreude at some point, but we needed the Germans to give us a word for it, so we borrowed that term, because it's pointing out something useful in our environment. And I feel the same way about wu-wei and there's no good translation for either term into English. And I think this is one powerful way
词汇在指出我们知识的空白方面非常有帮助。所以，每个人在某个时刻都会体验到“幸灾乐祸”（Schadenfreude），但我们需要德国人给我们提供一个词来表达它，所以我们借用了这个术语，因为它指出了我们环境中一些有用的东西。我对“无为”也有同样的感觉，这两个词都没有很好的英语翻译。我认为这是中国哲学帮助我们的一个有力方式，
in which Chinese philosophy helps us is it gives us a language for talking about this relationship between spontaneity and charisma or spontaneity and authenticity that is a bit of a blind spot in modern Western cultures. There's a brain imaging study involving jazz musicians that tells us what's happening in the brains of people when they are in an u-we state. Tell me about the study, Ted. What they found is that when the musicians were playing a set piece, so when they gave them particular music to play,
它为我们提供了一种语言，来谈论自发性与魅力，或自发性与真实性之间的关系，这在现代西方文化中是一个盲点。有一项涉及爵士乐手的脑成像研究告诉我们，当人们处于无为状态时，大脑中发生了什么。泰德，跟我说说这项研究。他们发现，当乐手们演奏固定曲目时，也就是当他们被要求演奏特定的音乐时，
or when they were playing scales, everything's firing. Their prefrontal cortex is firing. They're obviously exerting effort. When they're invited to improvise, so you know stop playing a particular piece just do whatever you want, there's this interesting pattern where the prefrontal cortex, so the center of cognitive control, executive function, doing things consciously, that part shuts down. But what's interesting is the ACC, the anterior cingulate cortex, is very active. So this seems to be the neural correlate of wu-wei,
或者当他们练习音阶时，大脑的所有部分都在活跃。他们的前额叶皮层在活跃。他们显然在付出努力。当他们被邀请即兴演奏时，也就是停止演奏特定曲目，随心所欲地演奏时，出现了一种有趣的模式：前额叶皮层（即认知控制中心、执行功能、有意识做事的中心）关闭了。但有趣的是，前扣带皮层（ACC）非常活跃。这似乎就是无为的神经相关物，
where the PFC is shut off, so we don't have the experience of effort or action. And yet we're alert and we're engaged and we're paying attention to what we're doing. And so it seems to be the state of kind of engagement, attention, but a feeling of no effort and no cognitive control. So much of the story that you're telling me here, Ted, is about being less focused on ourselves and more focused on the things that we are engaged with, focused on the outside world. You argue that in fact,
此时前额叶皮层关闭，所以我们没有努力或行动的体验。然而我们依然警觉、投入，并关注着我们正在做的事情。所以这似乎是一种投入、专注的状态，但没有努力感和认知控制感。泰德，你在这里讲述的很多故事，都是关于减少对自我的关注，更多地关注我们所参与的事物，关注外部世界。你认为事实上，
a strategy for entering Uwe is to focus on the outside world rather than on ourselves. Talk about how you can do this. You need to find something that you care about that's bigger than you. And that's going to be different things for different people. So for me, it's the Northern California landscape, the colors of it, the shape of the hills. It's gardening, if I'm weeding, chopping wood is great for that. Playing tennis, if it's danger tennis, if it's actually, I'm not worried about it too much,
进入无为的一种策略是关注外部世界而不是我们自己。谈谈你是如何做到这一点的。你需要找到一些你关心的、比你自身更宏大的事物。这对不同的人来说是不同的。对我来说，是北加州的风景、它的色彩、山丘的形状。是园艺，如果我在除草，劈柴对这种状态很有帮助。打网球，如果这是危险的网球，如果我不太担心它，
it'll get me into that state. Kayaking, I'm an ocean kayaker. I do kind of adventure kayaking. So I go out in the ocean and essentially do whitewater kayaking in the ocean. So I ride waves over rocks and through channels and surf. So I'm surrounded by this natural beauty. I have to be just completely focused on outside of me.
它会让我进入那种状态。皮划艇，我是一名海洋皮划艇运动员。我进行的是一种探险皮划艇运动。所以我去海洋里，本质上是在海洋里做激流皮划艇。所以我骑着浪越过岩石，穿过水道，冲浪。所以我被这种自然美景所包围。我必须完全专注于我之外的事物。
I have to be looking at the ocean and not at me. But everyone can find some activity that will get them into a way. I'm wondering if physical exertion is also valuable, Ted, because it's taking us out of our minds and into our bodies. I mean, when I'm doing push-ups or running or playing hard at a sport, it becomes harder to think. Can you talk about this idea that one of the benefits of intense exercise is that it can actually lead us to ouwe by essentially shutting down, if you will, some portion of the brain? Yeah. by essentially shutting down, if you will, some portion of the brain. Yeah, so the neuroscientist Ernie Dietrich
我必须看着海洋，而不是看着我自己。但每个人都能找到一些能让他们进入无为状态的活动。泰德，我想知道体力消耗是否有价值，因为它把我们从思想中带出来，进入我们的身体。我的意思是，当我做俯卧撑、跑步或进行激烈的体育运动时，思考变得更困难了。你能谈谈这个观点吗：剧烈运动的好处之一是，它可以通过本质上关闭大脑的某些部分，从而引导我们进入无为状态？是的，通过本质上关闭大脑的某些部分。是的，神经科学家厄尼·迪特里希（Arnie Dietrich）
did a lot of work on what he calls hypofrontality that was looking at this phenomenon. So when you're stressing your body, our body says, okay, we need to really send some blood to the muscles and to the heart. And so this accounts for this experience, long distance runners have of just euphoria. You know, I get it through weightlifting, where it's just at a certain point, the blood
在他所谓的“前额叶功能减退”（hypofrontality）方面做了大量工作，研究的就是这种现象。所以当你给身体施加压力时，我们的身体会说，好吧，我们需要真正地向肌肉和心脏输送一些血液。所以这解释了长跑运动员那种纯粹的欣快感。你知道，我通过举重获得这种感觉，在某个时刻，血液
flow is not going to my neocortex anymore. And I feel great. I feel exhilarated and absorbed in what I'm doing. And this is a kind of tricky way to get into wu-wei. What you're doing is using your body as a tool for indirectly shutting your mind down. So a lot of people use alcohol as a way to shut their mind down. Is that a way of getting to wu-wei, Ted?
不再流向我的新皮层。我感觉棒极了。我感到振奋，并沉浸在我所做的事情中。这是一种进入无为的巧妙方法。你所做的是利用你的身体作为一种工具，间接地关闭你的大脑。所以很多人利用酒精作为关闭大脑的一种方式。泰德，这是一种进入无为的方法吗？
There's a story in the Zhuangzi, this early Taoist text, that talks about a drunken man on a cart getting carried home from a party. When he falls out of the cart, but he's not hurt. He didn't know that he was riding and he doesn't know that he's falling out. So he's protected because his spirit is whole. I remember reading that and thinking, oh, that reminds me of something that happened in college
《庄子》这本早期道家著作中有一个故事，讲的是一个醉汉在马车上从聚会回家。当他从车上掉下来时，他并没有受伤。他不知道自己在乘车，也不知道自己正在掉下来。所以他受到了保护，因为他的精神是完整的。我记得读到这里时心想，哦，这让我想起了大学里发生的一件事，
where we got for a party and a friend of mine took a tumble down a slope and kind of popped up and bowed to us all and was like, ta-da, because he was so, he was relaxed. He didn't tense up, right? You get hurt when you fall, when you tense up. The Zhuangzi story concludes by saying if you can make your spirit whole in this way through alcohol, how much more so can you do it if
当时我们去参加聚会，我的一个朋友从斜坡上滚了下来，然后弹起来向我们鞠躬，说“当当！”，因为他当时非常放松。他没有紧张，对吧？当你摔倒时，如果你紧张，你就会受伤。庄子的故事结尾说，如果你能通过酒精以这种方式使你的精神完整，那么如果你
you're drunk on heaven? So in the Zhuangzi, it's very clearly just a metaphor. It's kind of sacred power. And you know, that's fine. But thinking about it more, I was like, but still alcohol is pretty good. It does the job in a lot of situations. You have to just drink this substance that will go into your bloodstream, go up to your brain and shut down your PFC for you. And so I got interested in alcohol
沉醉于天道，岂不更能做到这一点吗？所以在《庄子》中，这显然只是一个隐喻。这是一种神圣的力量。你知道，这很好。但深入思考后，我想，不过酒精确实相当不错。它在很多情况下都能奏效。你只需要喝下这种物质，它就会进入你的血液，到达你的大脑，为你关闭前额叶皮层。所以我对酒精
and other chemical intoxicants as cultural technologies that we've developed to essentially get around the paradox of trying not to try. Ted credits alcohol with once helping him finish writing a book proposal. He had been stuck a long time, but something changed after he had a couple of stiff drinks. I really felt like I was taking dictation. But what it really is, is you're letting your subconscious, your hot cognition, which is really clever, which can see new possibilities, you're letting it drive for a little while and not trying to do top-down control. and not trying to do top-down control. And that's what sold the book. It became the first few pages of the book. It's what everyone loves.
和其他化学致幻剂产生了兴趣，将它们视为我们开发的文化技术，本质上是为了绕过“试图不试图”的悖论。泰德将酒精归功于曾经帮助他完成了一份书稿。他被困了很长时间，但在喝了几杯烈酒后，情况发生了变化。我真的觉得我在听写。但实际上，你是在让你的潜意识（你的热认知，它非常聪明，能看到新的可能性）驱动一段时间，而不是试图进行自上而下的控制。而这正是这本书畅销的原因。它成为了书的前几页。这是每个人都喜欢的内容。
And I don't think I ever could have gotten there pounding coffee and staring at my computer screen. Edward Slingerlin is a professor of philosophy at the University of British Columbia. He is the author of Trying Not to Try, Ancient China, Modern Science, and the Power of Spontaneity. Ted, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me. There is a powerful form of effortlessness that we have not yet explored. Think about all the people who spend years
我不认为我能通过狂喝咖啡、盯着电脑屏幕达到那种程度。爱德华·斯林格兰（Edward Slingerland）是不列颠哥伦比亚大学的哲学教授。他是《试图不试图：中国古代、现代科学与自发性的力量》（Trying Not to Try）一书的作者。泰德，感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。谢谢你的邀请。有一种我们尚未探索的强大的无为形式。想想那些花费数年时间
trying to learn a new language. They take classes, spend time working with professors, pour over books in the library. Some go on lengthy foreign trips to immerse themselves in the new language. It's all very effortful. Sadly, most people who try to learn a new language fail to do so. But notice how nearly all of us, in the first year or two of our lives, miraculously pick up the language or languages spoken by the people around
试图学习一门新语言的人。他们上课，花时间与教授一起工作，在图书馆里研读书籍。有些人进行长期的国外旅行，让自己沉浸在新语言中。这一切都非常费力。遗憾的是，大多数试图学习新语言的人都失败了。但请注意，我们几乎所有人，在生命的前一两年里，奇迹般地掌握了周围人所说的语言。
us. Remember, this is at a time when we can barely stand, we might not know how to walk, we can't feed ourselves, but we effortlessly master something that adults take years and years to do. How does this happen and what can it teach us about the science of effortless action? That and more are in our accompanying episode on Hidden Brain Plus. It's titled, Letting Go. If you're already a subscriber, you can listen to it right now. If you're not a subscriber, there are two ways you can join Hidden Brain Plus. If you listen to the show on Apple Podcasts, you can sign up for a free 7-day subscription
记住，那时我们几乎站不稳，可能还不知道怎么走路，不能自己进食，但我们却毫不费力地掌握了成年人需要花费数年时间才能做到的事情。这是怎么发生的？它能教给我们关于无为行动科学的什么知识？这些内容以及更多信息都在我们的《隐藏的大脑 Plus》配套剧集中。标题是《放手》（Letting Go）。如果你已经是订阅者，现在就可以收听。如果你不是订阅者，有两种方式可以加入《隐藏的大脑 Plus》。如果你在 Apple Podcasts 上收听节目，你可以注册 7 天免费订阅，
by searching for HiddenBrain and clicking the Try Free button or by going to apple.co slash hiddenbrain. Another option, especially if you are using an Android device, is to sign up for HiddenBrain Plus via our Patreon page. To do so just go to support.hiddenbrain.org. That site again is support.hiddenbrain.org. No matter which option you choose, your subscription helps us make many more episodes of the show. We're truly grateful. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media.
方法是搜索 HiddenBrain 并点击“免费试用”按钮，或者访问 apple.co/hiddenbrain。另一个选择，特别是如果你使用的是安卓设备，是通过我们的 Patreon 页面注册《隐藏的大脑 Plus》。要这样做，只需访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。再次重复，网址是 support.hiddenbrain.org。无论你选择哪种方式，你的订阅都能帮助我们制作更多节目。我们衷心感谢。Hidden Brain 由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。
Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. We end today with a story from our sister show, My Unsung Hero. It's brought to you by T-Mobile for Business. Our story comes from Joy Diaz. Joy grew up in Mexico City. Although her parents were anything but wealthy, they devoted themselves to humanitarian work.
我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗（Annie Murphy-Paul）、克里斯汀·王（Kristen Wong）、劳拉·奎雷尔（Laura Quirell）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）、安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）和尼克·伍德伯里（Nick Woodbury）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是 Hidden Brain 的执行编辑。今天我们以来自我们的姐妹节目《我未被歌颂的英雄》（My Unsung Hero）的一个故事结束。它由 T-Mobile for Business 为您呈现。我们的故事来自乔伊·迪亚兹（Joy Diaz）。乔伊在墨西哥城长大。虽然她的父母一点也不富有，但他们致力于人道主义工作。
By collaborating with a network of people from around the world, they were able to support a community living in extreme poverty. And when I talk about extreme poverty, what I mean is these people lived inside the municipal garbage dump. And my parents had no money, but what they had was a lot of faith and they worked tirelessly to bring teachers and doctors to work into the garbage dump and help the people who live there. And eventually as time went by, my parents were able to build a clinic, they built a school, they built public showers, they built a dining hall, all of that in the
通过与来自世界各地的人们合作，他们能够支持一个生活在极端贫困中的社区。当我谈到极端贫困时，我的意思是这些人住在市政垃圾填埋场里。我的父母没有钱，但他们拥有坚定的信念，他们不知疲倦地工作，带医生和老师进入垃圾填埋场，帮助住在那里的人们。最终，随着时间的推移，我的父母能够建立一个诊所，他们建了一所学校，建了公共淋浴间，建了一个食堂，所有这些都在
middle of the garbage dump. But while that was happening, we did not have a home. We were renters. And I remember one day, one of those doctor missionaries, he flew into Mexico City, hopped in a taxi, came to the house, saw my mom and just gave her this paper bag full of money, full of cash. I don't know how much money was in that bag. I am thinking about $50,000. And he said, for many years, I've been wanting to buy a house for you. So here's the money. Buy a house. And because of his gift, we were able to move into a middle class neighborhood.
垃圾填埋场的中间。但在那期间，我们没有自己的家。我们是租房住的。我记得有一天，其中一位医生传教士飞到墨西哥城，跳上一辆出租车，来到我们家，见到我妈妈，给了她一个装满钱的纸袋，全是现金。我不知道那个袋子里有多少钱。我想大约有 5 万美元。他说，多年来，我一直想为你买一套房子。所以这是钱。去买套房子吧。因为他的礼物，我们得以搬进了一个中产阶级社区。
And because of his gift, you know, the money that was spent in rent was now saved and I was able to go to college. And that changed not only the trajectory of my life, but I believe wholeheartedly that it changed the trajectory of generations because today my children live in a middle-class neighborhood because I am college-educated, because I am able to have a better job than I could have had before, you know, like it changed the trajectory of generations. I want to say his name. My unsung hero is Jack Bloxham from Richmond, Virginia. I am forever grateful, Jack. Thank you.
因为他的礼物，你知道，原本花在房租上的钱现在省了下来，我得以去上大学。这不仅改变了我的人生轨迹，而且我全心全意地相信，它改变了几代人的轨迹，因为今天我的孩子们住在一个中产阶级社区，因为我受过大学教育，因为我能拥有一份比以前更好的工作，你知道，它改变了几代人的轨迹。我想说出他的名字。我未被歌颂的英雄是来自弗吉尼亚州里士满的杰克·布洛克瑟姆（Jack Bloxham）。我永远感激你，杰克。谢谢。
Joy Diaz now lives in Austin, Texas. Today's My Unsung Hero story was brought to you by T-Mobile for Business. If you enjoy Hidden Brain, please take a moment and share your favorite episode with two or three people in your life. Word of mouth recommendations really make a huge difference in introducing new listeners
乔伊·迪亚兹现在住在德克萨斯州奥斯汀。今天的《我未被歌颂的英雄》故事由 T-Mobile for Business 为您呈现。如果你喜欢《隐藏的大脑》，请花点时间与你生活中的两三个人分享你最喜欢的一集。口碑推荐在向新听众介绍
to our work. We truly appreciate your support. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的工作方面真的起到了巨大的作用。我们衷心感谢你的支持。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。很快再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。